die schweiz ort der zuflucht und des
protests hat sich immer für die
einhaltung der menschenrechte eingesetzt
im digitalen zeitalter wird sie die
wiege einer mächtigen untergrundszene
von hackern und kämpfern für ein freies
internet von zürich bis bern diskutieren
kritisieren und klären die aktivisten
seit jahrzehnten über die
begleiterscheinung unserer technik
basierten gesellschaft auf sie wagt sich
nun aus der anonymität um uns die augen
zu öffnen über die am magneten der
schweiz macht auch sozusagen als
instrument der kontrolle und zwar durch
die beeinflussung von menschen auf
emotionaler ebene genutzt werden kann
die leute verstehen einfach nicht was
ihr passiert und das ist bedenklich wir
sind häufig werden werden wir nicht
gehört oder unsere argumente sind
weniger wert als andere überlegungen
niemand wagt mehr sich zur frage wie
weit ein geheimdienst überhaupt gehen
darf ohne dass er die freiheitliche
grundordnung zerstört dir eigentlich
beschützen sollten
[Musik]
entscheidende wendung am 11 april 2009
10 der seit sieben jahren in der
londoner botschafter ecuadors
eingesperrte julian assange wird
schließlich aus seinem versteck gejagt
um sich vor gericht zu verantworten
so ruft sich der gründer von wikileaks
das darauf spezialisiert ist
diplomatische geheimnisse publik zu
machen
in unserer erinnerung zurück der blonde
engel zum hassobjekt der regierung
geworden befindet sich mittlerweile in
der hand derer die er heraus forderte
seine rabiate verhaftung stößt eine
fundamentale debatte an nämlich die über
informationsfreiheit überwachung ist
also von anfang an ein machtinstrument
gewesen um kontrolle auszuüben
über diejenigen die kommunizieren zu
wissen was dort kommuniziert wird ein
vorteil für sich selber daraus zu ziehen
wir bewegen uns also sozusagen wieder in
einen föderalismus zurück in dem eine
kleine elitäre gruppe von menschen das
geschick der gesamten entscheid bestimmt
[Musik]
juli ist das mediale gesicht eines neuen
klassenkampfes im digitalen zeitalter
einerseits kontrollieren multinationale
tech unternehmen die informationskanäle
und die datenspeicherung andererseits
sehen die weitere hacker daten als
allgemein gut an und setzen sich dafür
ein die durch hacking von
informationssystemen öffentlich
zugänglich zu machen
das kann einem kriminell vorkommen doch
dieser hacktivismus zielt darauf unsere
grundrechte im internet und in der
gesellschaft zu verteidigen
gegen wen gegen regierung und die großen
unternehmen die die technik nutzen und
dominieren um ihre kontrolle über die
zivilgesellschaft zu stützen
in bern ist simon gantenbein eines der
gesichter dieses aktivismus seit 2011
engagiert sich der informatiker bei der
digitalen gesellschaft
diese schweizer ngo verteidigt die
grundrechte im digitalen zeitalter
weil was wir im moment sehen ist dass
das internet kommerzialisiert wird wir
verlieren täglich unsere freiheiten und
vielfach ist es auch so dass bei
gewissen ideen oder neuen sachen die
kommen die technik zwar alles erlaubt
aber man sich den konsequenzen im
endeffekt gar nicht bewusst ist
die schweiz ist die wiege der
menschenrechte und der demokratie
vorbildlich ist sie nicht elektronische
stimmabgabe überwachung elektronische
patientenakte die eidgenossenschaft
glänzt durch ihre unfähigkeit die
tragweite der forderungen von seiten der
hacker community zu verstehen
eine gesellschaft zu errichten die die
menschenrechte im digitalzeitalter
achtet
ich denke aber auch dass diese vision
nicht durch technische mittel erreichbar
ist sondern das ist eine sehr politische
frage das heißt es ist eine frage an die
an die menschen was wollt ihr eigentlich
wie wollt ihr leben mit 57 jahren ist
bernd fix eine galionsfigur der ältesten
hacker bewegung der erde des chaos
computer club der 1981 in berlin
gegründete club entwickelte ideen wie
man technische möglichkeit zur freiheit
statt zu unterdrücken nutzen kann
er befasst sich mit zensur im netz
datenspeicherung und allen instrumenten
zur gesellschaftlichen kontrolle im
digitalen zeitalter
seit den 2000er jahren unterhält der
chaos computer club einen äußerst
aktiven ableger in zürich stehen heute
ganz andere technische möglichkeiten
mittel zur verfügung die ihren einfluss
auf die gesellschaft geltend machen und
die wir sehr kritisch betrachten müssen
diese befürchtungen gab es schon vor den
sozialen netzwerken und der künstlichen
intelligenz der nabu strategie dennoch
gefühl
[Musik]
die hacker bewegung entsteht in den usa
in den 60er jahren
sie steht am anfang eines prophetischen
textes dass sein verband meine festo von
1993 zeigt eine zukunft voraus in der
unsere leben in datenzentren gespeichert
und von einer technik elite genutzt wird
genau so ist es gekommen keine regierung
scheint es jedoch gelesen zu haben
warum hacker wurden immer für paranoid
oder technik extremisten gehalten aber
der ausdruck hacker hat nichts
abwertendes er bezeichnet die jenigen
die technische möglichkeiten verstehen
wollen sie kritisch beleuchten
auseinanderbauen bis beim kaputt machen
aber nur um sie an schließlich für sich
und andere nutzbar zu machen hernani
marquez ist aktivist beim chaos computer
club schweiz in zürich
nach aussage des informatikers werden
hacker nicht gehört weil sie eine
tiefgreifende infragestellung der
gesellschaft fordern
ich bin als rassistisch motiviert hier
also ich glaube nicht an solche systeme
dieser völlig zentralistische und ich
versuche das ist auch wunderbar in line
mit den setzte prinzip in die
zentralisierung zu fördern
wir müssen das internet dezentralisieren
wir müssen ende zu ende verschlüsselung
ausrollen eine dezentralisierung des
netzes ist schwer zu erreichen
in der schweiz wie anderswo weiß die
zivilgesellschaft über die probleme bei
der daten kontrolle und manipulation im
internet muss bescheid wikileaks
markiert dass 2010 ein bruch je stärker
die regierung ihre muskeln spielen
lassen desto sichtbarer wird der
aktivismus ägypten demonstriert dass im
februar 2011 öffentlich auf dem gipfel
des arabischen frühlings cup das land
das internet um die volksproteste in die
knie zu zwingen
von einem moment auf den anderen ist
ägypten von aller kommunikation
abgeschnitten
in zeiten des terrors sind diese werte
auf einmal weniger wert und dafür setzen
wir uns ein dass es eben nicht dazu
kommt es ist ein schwieriger kampf ein
langer kampf aber wenn wir grund und
menschenrechte verlieren dann verlieben
wird es endlich unsere freiheit eine
tiefgreifende gesellschaft debatte
entsteht 2013 mit den enthüllungen durch
adwords noten
angesichts der totalen überwachung
washington ziehen sich staaten zurück um
nicht länger unter amerikanischer
vorherrschaft über das internet zu
stehen brasilien will sein eigenes
internet russland china indien auch in
zufolge ist das netz ein derart
wichtiger ökonomischer und politischer
hebel geworden dass er mehr regulierung
benötigt sie bezichtigen die usa einer
vorherrschaft mit seinen etwa 15
diplomatie organisation spielt das
internationale genf den schiedsrichter
in diesem machtkampf um das internet
die attentate von paris 2015 eine neue
gelegenheit dem internet einen maulkorb
anzulegen
die regierung verkündet ein gesetz das
eine stärkere überwachung der netzwerke
angesichts der terroristischen bedrohung
die in frankreich den ausnahmezustand
auf die technischen mittel aus diese
illusion dass mehr überwachung mehr
sicherheit gibt diese illusion wurde
ganz erfolgreich von von von politikern
in allen westlichen ländern in den
letzten jahren gestreut dabei ist ja
heute das problem nicht dass man zu
wenig informationen hat sondern wünsche
und dass man zu viele informationen
haben für diejenigen die die freiheiten
im internet verteidigen dienen diese
angriffe auf die privatsphäre nur dazu
kontroverse überwachungsmethoden zu
rechtfertigen was uns stört an der
ganzen diskussion ist dass man nicht
sieht was damit eigentlich bezweckt wird
letzten endes letzten endes kann man
damit wirklich die gesellschaft
kontrollieren warum wird überwacht und
das ist für viele menschen nicht direkt
zugänglich
der kampf gegen terrorismus veranlasst
auch die schweiz ihr überwachungs gesetz
zu verschärfen
am 25 september 2015 stimmen zwei
drittel der schweizer dafür
ende der 80er jahre hat man sich dagegen
gewehrt bei einer volkszählung
mitzumachen und die fragen dort waren
harmlos also jeder von uns gibt in den
sozialen netzwerken mehr preis als diese
volkszählung von damals mit der
unterstützung der gerichte haben
schweizerische spione freihand dafür
jegliche internationale kommunikation
abzufangen die die schweiz durchquert
sie können e-mails filtern telefone
abhören und das netz nach schlagworten
durchsuchen die schweiz rühmt sich
dessen nicht doch sie besaß schon immer
eine überwachungs wirtschaft laser und
kommunikationssysteme software in 64
ländern exportiert werden seine
technischen güter mit doppeltem
verwendungszweck ein lukrativer markt
der sich auf beträchtliche staatlichen
budgets verlassen kann
es ist relativ schwierig für den staat
das zu entscheiden aber im zweifel
sollte man nicht an länder liefern wo
die menschenrechte
max ist ein toter sehr klein gehalten
werden was natürlich gegen die
interessen eines wirtschafts
departements ist die möglichst viel
absatz machen müssen und das ist ein
spannungsfeld
ist der export von waffentechnik deshalb
ein zukunftsmarkt
beim thema überwachung haben google
apple facebook oder amazon sehr viel
gewaltigere instrumente die
kalifornischen riesen haben es
verstanden sich für die politik finanz
und militär eliten unverzichtbar zu
machen
vor allem ist es ihm gelungen ihre
aktivitäten gut zu verbergen
die presse präsentiert sie als
mustergültige unternehmen doch wie
funktionieren sie das wissen wir nicht
im geringsten ihre algorithmen die
unsere daten verwalten speichern
monetarisieren ein betriebsgeheimnis
ist das nicht die höchste form von macht
allein die tatsache dass wir heute
darüber diskutieren wie es möglich ist
es eine private firma wie facebook in
der lage ist politische prozesse
vielleicht sogar wahlen zu beeinflussen
zeigt dass diese grenze zwischen privat
und staatlich durchlässig wird dass sie
transparenter wird
wir leben in einem zeitalter wo quasi
fakten irgendwie zunehmend keine rolle
mehr spielen also fake nims zeitalter
sozusagen als da wäre ich auf kleidung
nötige versuchen sie zu bieten aber die
leute verstehen es einfach offenbar
nicht was wohin das führt die technik
sollte den menschen immer ein teil ihrer
täglichen entscheidungen abnehmen
doch wir wurden vorhersehbar und
zugunsten von profiten privater
unternehmen manipulierbar sind die
algorithmen schuld es ist beunruhigend
zu sehen wie allgegenwärtig diese
mathematischen formeln sind denn die
allmächtigen algorithmen der silicon
valley stilisieren sich zu moralischen
autoritäten die entscheiden was richtig
und falsch gut und schlecht ist der
gegenstand der diskussion ist also nicht
technischer sondern ethischer
politischer ökonomischer
gesellschaftlicher und philosophischer
natur algorithmen erschaffen ein
universum das die weltsicht ihrer
schöpfer widerspiegelt in welcher
realität leben wir also